- [Instructor] Often when we think about
the beginning of American history,
we think 1776, with the
Declaration of Independence,
or maybe 1492, when Columbus
arrived in the Americas.
But the history of America really begins
about 15,000 years ago,
when people first arrived in the Americas.
In this video, I want to
provide a very brief overview
of native societies before contact
to give you an idea of just how diverse
and complex these societies were,
as native groups adapted to
and interacted with their environments.
Now there's recently
been a scholarly debate
about how people first arrived.
We know that maybe 12,000 years ago,
during an ice age, the
sea level was lower,
and so a spit of land in between
the Americas and Asia was exposed,
over which people may have traveled.
But recent archeological evidence suggests
that people were perhaps
already in the Americas
at the time of this ice age,
so it's possible
that they may have come earlier in boats.
Now however it was that they arrived,
they spread north and south
and east throughout the Americas
so that by the time that Europeans
arrived in the late 1400s
there were perhaps 50
million people.
That's kind of a mid-range
number for the estimates,
that historians have made,
living in the Americas.
And of those, four to six million
were living in North America.
So how did these societies develop?
Well, a really big moment
was around 5000 BCE,
when people in Mexico domesticated corn,
maize, as it's also known.
And domesticating maize meant that people
who had originally been
hunters, gatherers,
following herds of animals
could partake in settled agriculture.
So they could develop
villages, complex societies.
This isn't to say that they
stopped hunting or gathering,
but they began staying in one place.
So let's zoom in a little
bit and take a look
at some of the major
societies in these regions.
Native American societies developed
around their natural environments,
using the resources that
were available to them.
For example, the Southwest,
Plains and Great Basin
were quite dry.
A lot of desert.
And so societies in these regions
adapted to the dry
climate in several ways.
For example, Native American groups
that lived on the Great Plains
continued their hunting
and gathering way of life.
Hunting bison,
and following the herds of animals
in teepees,
which were dwellings that were easy
to set up and then take down.
People in the Southwest, like
the Ancestral Puebloan people,
dealt with this dry environment
by creating very complex
irrigation projects
so that they could water their maize crops
using what little moisture there was.
The Puebloans lived in
large cave complexes
as agriculture allowed them
to grow their population.
In the Northwest,
fishing in the Pacific Ocean
gave Native Americans a
plentiful source of food,
while farming allowed the Mississippian peoples
to develop large
settlements, like Cahokia,
near modern day St.
Louis, which, at its peak,
may have had as many as 25,000-40,000 residents.
The Mississippians and other
East Coast native peoples
relied a lot on what's known
as three-sister farming,
in which people would plant
corn, beans and squash together,
which was mutually beneficial
to all three plants,
as the corn served as a trellis for the beans,
and the squash protected the root system of the corn.
All three together create
a very nutritious diet,
which allowed for a relatively
high population density
on the East Coast.
So by the time that
Europeans began to arrive
in the late 1400s and 1500s,
native societies had been
evolving for over 14,000 years.
But the introduction of
European people, pathogens,
plants, and animals would introduce
an unprecedented amount
of change in the Americas.